how much was that easy odd plane ticket
it's the most expensive plane ticket in
the world 50 grand
unbelievable but like the whole story
i i started watching like i got to the
video so i didn't want to did you did
you say how much it was on the video
i might have i don't remember but it
three
room suite on the plane an
airplane and and where you're flying to
[ __ ] abu dhabi you like
um so it goes like this so how do you
get those dudes so i've always been
obsessed with like
first class yeah because i spent the
first like 10 years of my
real career where i was traveling
non-stop whatever's cheapest
middle seats in the back or whatever the
shittiest airline is that's what i fly
and like the more you pass by those
seats up front you start to get a little
obsessed
i went through all of these like
different versions of obsession like
finally figure out how to almost always
fly first without ever paying for it
that was like mid-2000s casey where i
didn't have any money but i got really
good at faking it
wow and then like and i started to find
success and
i'm still sort of obsessed with flying
even though i don't get on planes
anymore
but what happened was i think it was
2016.
youtube at the height of my daily
vlogging youtube said
come be a speaker at our brand cast like
our annual summit
in australia and i said i can't it's a
two-day flight and i need to make a
daily vlog
i was like i'll tell you what if you fly
me through dubai so i can go on this
fancy plane
i can make videos about the flight
they're like sure no problem
except for they bought me a [ __ ]
business class ticket
not first class and i was like okay i'll
just play two bedrooms instead of well
that's the thing
is like they like sent me a business
class i was like [ __ ] i said first and
then like
i was like wow they spent like 10 grand
on this ticket and i was like i'm not
going to say anything like i can't
complain like who the [ __ ] am i
so i made the video about flying their
business class and it was like fine
and people watched the video and stuff
i'm flying back also business class
the airline pulls me aside they had seen
my video
and they wanted me to try out their
first class experience
that's how i got the free [ __ ] first
class on the flight so does that mean
you had to turn around and go back after
your return
no it was a flight from dubai back
that's right so i'm fine
i'm flying back from the states like my
return flight they saw it when i was in
australia
right because i'm uploading like i shoot
the video today so
they they grabbed you they grabbed you
on your connection
and you buy literally like going down
the run going down the street and i got
all my cameras
i'm talking to myself i'm like excuse me
mister nice and i was like [ __ ] please
don't say i can't film on this flight
please don't say it
and they're like we've been we're able
to upgrade you to first class and i'm
like
me this is like all this is like a
culmination of every dream i've
so that's what happened then i made that
video and that video did like 70 million
views
so that immediately after that like i
don't know six months later or something
like
that same airline that airlines called
what's it called no
emirates i'm not even at et hot yet
emirates
announces some new first class situation
everybody on youtube
twitter is like casey you should check
this one out and sure enough like
they reach out and they're like hey you
want to try our new first and i was like
i do
i do so they're like we only fly from
zurich though and i was like oh i've got
no plans to be in switzerland like who
the [ __ ] am i some international like
banker man of mystery and they're like
we'll bring you to switzerland
and i was like great i'll go to
switzerland i'll ski so they
flew me in their plane i remember
getting on that plane and i was like
they're showing me all the first class
cabins and no one's in them
and i'm like whoa when do you board the
rest of flight and they're like no we
haven't actually launched this yet
you're the only person in this cabin and
i was like oh
yeah whoa okay so that was number two
then we get to the ultimate which is
this etihad
it's called like the apartment because
you get three rooms you get a bedroom
you get a bathroom with a shower in it
and then you get a living room with a
big screen tv and then you get a hallway
which connects all of them
it's bigger than this without a doubt
square footage-wise it's bigger than
this van that we're in
bigger than my
and the difference was they paid me for
that like that was a
paid job and the thing is had they
offered me the job without the paycheck
i would have said yes
if they had offered me the job for a
discounted ticket price
i would have paid them to get on that
plane
and they flew me in like i was like you
know
very sort of meek about it but i was
like you know i'm vegan if there's if
there are any options
i get on the plane they have this menu
and like my name is embossed in the lev
leather cover and it's like menu
a la casey neistat and then in
parentheses everything's vegan
and it was like options vegan options
like
six of them and then they just brought
me everything on the menu because they
had made it all for me like it was so
insane wow and then like you get in the
bed and like i was so overwhelmed by the
idea that i'm laying in a bed
on an airplane that i wasn't able to
sleep like it was just too exciting
it's just like the shower like how the
shower works there's literally a
timer it goes from green to red
but like i think i had six minutes of
showering but six minutes of showering
is also three
two minute showers so i broke those
showers up
i was showering the whole flight home no
that was really exciting but like
that video did you know 30 million views
or something so i
i don't know what how i don't know how
to equate that value but you have to
imagine that it was a much better deal
for the airline
how do you make a commercial that gets a
10-minute commercial
that gets 30 million views for the price
of a stupid ticket
right [ __ ] amazing dude how that's so
fortunate
you became the like the first class guy
you know like what a great lane to
be in you know what's what's crazy is
that prior to becoming that guy i
remember watching
all of these first class videos because
i was obsessed with it
and like all these videos sucks but they
have crazy views because anyone who's
ever been on an airplane is forced to
walk by
those seats you're like god i wish i
knew everything about those seats and i
was like if i ever get the opportunity
i'm gonna go ape [ __ ]
and i had like this list in my head of
what's wrong with every airline review
and it's like the camera's too narrow so
it looks tiny it's claustrophobic and
the lighting's terrible
so like on those flights i requested
like i made sure it's a day flight
so the lighting would be good lighting's
everything dark on an airplane does not
work i tried to do it i've made a couple
videos where it's dark it looks gross
and then like all these it has to be on
a tripod you can't hand hold the camera
on an airplane there's too much action
if the camera isn't fixed you're
stressed out when you're trying to watch
it
you can't see what you're looking at so
like get that shot like all of this [ __ ]
i obsessed over
and if you go and walk back and watch
any of those videos you realize that
like
every shot like that etihad no emirates
playing that i was the only person in
the first class cabin
i was the first person to fly in that
cabin and i did major damage so i was
like breaking through the
ceiling panels so i could mount a camera
up there and i did that in all these
different locations like
i was trying to be as respectful as
possible but i was like the shot's kind
of more important than me not scratching
the wall here
and i would bet that they would agree
with that because that video did insane
views
for sure you know it's so good man
what's your favorite airline that's so
hard um
i mean i like jet blue because they're
nice
like those those um middle eastern
airlines are insanely nice but that's
like
that's like saying oh rolls-royce has
more comfortable seats than my honda and
it's like okay
but like my old toyota was the best car
i ever owned even though it's not as
fancy as a rolls-royce i don't
know rolls-royce i'm just trying to make
a bad analogy here i feel like i feel
like other parts of the world
besides america they really have the
customer service down at like a hotel
like good evening sir how are you
here how may i assist you like in japan
they bow to you and they
just want to accommodate your every
needs here they're just like [ __ ] it
what do you want
yeah it's unfortunate but like i think
like my
the hardest part of flying on planes is
like my wife right now is booking a trip
back east for this summer with the kids
and stuff and she's flying with her mom
i'm driving i'm literally gonna drive my
truck from l.a to new york because i
don't want to fly
um not that i'm against it but like i've
had the opportunity to drive i'd much
rather drive
it's tough man with the [ __ ] masks on
the plane dude
it's so like the reason why i'm i'm i
have such like anxiety about flying is
not because of like i'm worried about
getting sick
i have my vaccine i'm not worried like
it's everybody else like
it's that guy that yells at that lady
for not wearing her mask like i don't
want to be around that energy
yeah you're like stuck in this tube 30
000 feet in the sky with like
200 people and like if any percent of
them are angry at any other percentage
of them like i don't want to be a part
of that
and that [ __ ] stress it freaks me out
wow
yeah yeah dude have you always been like
that
be careful the energy you hang out with
no i've definitely gotten super weird as
i've gotten older
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole yeah
yeah dude